p es el centro del arco verde la medida
del ángulo p es de 0.4 radiales y la
longitud del radio es de 5 unidades
encuentre la longitud del arco verde
para conceptualizar mejor esto puedan
imaginarse que p es el centro de una
circunferencia más o menos así que se
extiende de este lado y de este otro
lado más o menos así y este ángulo de
acá es de punto 4 radiales que
intersecta a este arco verde de acá
antes de resolverlo nos invitó a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de pensar en
esto por su cuenta qué longitud tiene el
arco tomando en cuenta la información
que nos proporcionan bueno lo que
tenemos que hacer es recordar que es un
radio una forma de pensar en que es un
radial es seguiremos el arco y el ángulo
que lo interceptan y pensamos en su
longitud la longitud de este arco verde
va a ser de 0.4 radios
pero no queremos la longitud en radios
las unidades están en esta longitud del
radio este radio mide 5 unidades por lo
que la longitud del arco será 0.4 radios
por 5 unidades
entre radios ya que los radios de esta
circunferencia miden 5 unidades estos
radios se van a cancelar y nos va a
quedar una longitud en unidades de 1.4
por 5 igual a 22 unidades
mide la longitud de este arco verde
recordamos de nuevo cuando tenemos un
ángulo en radial es una forma de pensar
en ello es que la longitud del arco que
no esté secta va a ser la medida de este
ángulo irradian es por los radios o por
la longitud del radio que tenga esta
circunferencia a la que pertenece este
arco y cada radio en este caso mide 5
unidades así que no salió que la
longitud es de punto 4 radios por 5
unidades por radio de largo que es 2